hello and welcome to this video playing
doors played him or her once
13,000 blitz games wow that's a lot okay
I'm going for something a little bit
different yeah the g6 base setup while
it usually don't play that much know why
it was just very much intending to play
the setup pretty much that I guess
regardless of what I was going for and
now we have this symmetrical English
I went aged 6 cm because 95 is a bit of
an annoyance yeah how do we play this
him what is going to play for B form
[Music]
yeah probably I will just play in a very
standard standard fashion 90 of 6 you
oftentimes want to have this diagonal
open but it's actually not that that
easy to accomplish
thank you with the e6 stuff to play
ecigs earlier because then the bishop is
somewhat stranded um tell me I'm not
really sure I like my position all that
much
why does this before I dim it with some
some sort of play on the queenside
yeah I think white is probably not going
to be better in such a position but it's
not quite obvious what I'm doing
okay well this this is certainly
possible 95 but I'd feel Sun critical to
me you know like after Bishop takes h6
is hanging yeah this is a very
symmetrical position his called rook c1
c6 as an idea well for me it's not as
easy I mean I can go rook c3 in some
cases
the door this um how do we how do we go
about this position is it going to play
the D pawn that seems mmm not really
if I think
it can easily happen here that we just
have a position where there is very
little conflict going on because it's
difficult to make any headway I'm trying
to just look at the coupon
I don't think f3 is high on his wish
list and it was constantly under attack
so it seemed now Quinta CA aid okay so
that he can play look see it next I'm
not unhappy about this trade because
once we trade the d5 pawn becomes
vulnerable it's maybe maybe not really
important now that I think of it mmm
yeah it it's not it's not important
you can always cover it with the Queen
coming to see sex well I wanna take
every queen f5 or so he always has Queen
to see sex
hmm okay he will play Queen a you play
Roxy - if I play b5 here b5 Roxy talking
of and Quincy one take Jake and then 26
at the end I can actually take because
I'm quick enough with the king so let's
start with b5 Roxy - very likely you
know Quincy six is just blundering the
pawn basically and my idea
next is Queen b7 that would almost okay
that is that is fine no problem ready
and now Queen - b7 I could have done
that also instead of keeping the h6 pawn
but instead of yeah keeping it or moving
it away yeah Queen d7 it's my demon what
is White's idea yeah it's a little bit
man don't want to trade it's a little
bit odd that's square but there's really
no reason to trade
the bishops are both not great really
not so now how do you keep the poor now
I'm not threatening to take it
immediately because there's Quincy aid
mate so if he moves the King oh really
surprising we have sex and then I'm
nearing the corn and win it
let's prevent can you form
yeah
winning the pong man let's do that ready
for a bishop age six first animals c6 is
not urgent to take yeah it'll slowly
slowly got somewhere so let's see him
yeah here this is something that can
only be equal which is not rare sorry
I'm not very confrontational that same
yeah 95 I thought was a bit bit
surprising I don't think this is any way
out anywhere near playing for an
advantage but what of course should not
be worse
Luke c1 yeah I'm a little bit quicker on
the C file after it go into a form that
is an interesting idea but I like this
hmm why is that so good I don't I don't
understand
let's see I'm sorry my screen a for so
strong I would think that this is just
okay no of course it's gone - really - I
was stupid and then this makes a lot of
sense of course him rook c2 was a pretty
big threat huh didn't see it at all yeah
now he's okay
I mean I anticipated that and I thought
okay this must be fine look see true
okay and it's still okay for Wyatt but
somehow he lost a lot yeah after this
it's difficult they're still King to g1
that is what I expected I cannot take it
that's a neat table mate yeah I probably
would have played King to de 7 which is
not mentioned by the engine surprisingly
my queen c6 okay yeah this is a drawer
yeah probably would have stumbled into
that King the a tower versus better now
I'm covering the maid and pawn is
hanging the engine now gives a line with
a form but this is of course better from
like this is just not going away this
weakness you know I have a little
something down and yeah now you have to
be a little bit precise yeah not King d8
because of c7 so first this King d8 King
of three I think I should trollee
prevent key for I wasn't completely
certain IG for now is it good enough
okay yeah I mean I have a somewhat
awkward placement that's definitely true
so f5 is advised by the comp preventing
g4 it's kind of the same idea to not
allow King you for yeah after that are
probably winning
ferrets mate Bishop h6 checkmate they
only move and I'm winning we need the
house now
yeah it was very it was very dry but may
you can continue and keep setting the
problem and yeah sometimes
yeah steady yeah being persistent with
the load ideas will pay off thanks a lot
for watching